it has been a year since a las vegas man
was hit and killed on his motorized
wheelchair and his family is still
searching for answers tonight they
gathered to mark the one-year
anniversary of his death as police still
search for the suspect involved in the
crash sasha loftis joins us live in the
northeast valley with this story you'll
only see here on 8 news now
denise and brian it may have been an
entire year but renick lambie's family
still works every day to keep his
memorial alive tonight relatives
gathered to remember him and plead for
the closure they've wanted for so long
right here father god where my husband
got hit father god
365 days of sadness pain and so many
unanswered questions
here's our cry oh god the family of
renick lambie gathered friday to mark
one year since his life was suddenly
stolen we will always continue to speak
out we first introduced you to renick's
wife and son in november of 2020 right
after the 61 year old was hit and killed
by a car while riding his motorized
wheelchair here on abel's lane near lake
mead and lamb we're still believing for
justice we're still believing for
you know
the right thing police are still
searching for the suspect sharing a
photo of this car they believe to be
involved in the crash the way that he
died
and still
how that there is no closure this family
that's faced unimaginable grief is still
pleading for justice
some relatives even gathering from their
home country of belize we don't leave
things like this to just go unpunished
or unjust memories and love from las
vegas and a world away
fueling a need to know why they're still
in the back of our mind like who did
this
renick was hit right here on abel's lane
on november 12th again of last year
around 5 30 p.m if you have any
information as to who may have been
involved in this crash that car you saw
in the story here you are asked to call
metro police or crime stoppers to remain
anonymous reporting live tonight sasha
loftis live local now